in this video we are going to talk about  what is the MAC address let me remind  you this has got nothing to do with the  Big Mac or the Mac operating system now  before we get into the details let me  give you an analogy now we have three  people John Bob and Mary in a room who  want to talk now John when he wants to  talk to Mary he says hi Mary how are you  doing when Mary listens to this message  how does she know that she has to  respond to John it's through his voice  so she she replies to John but not Bob  saying hey John I'm doing good now if  you have three different computers who  want to talk to each other they don't  have any names so to bring the analogy  of names and identification to computers  we have this concept of MAC address  which is unique to each computers  network interface card